compétent non jean-jacques
servan-schreiber qui était directeur de
l'express a eu le bonheur de faire
travailler en même temps dans son
journal
françois mauriac et albert camus et
albert camus pendant une petite année
c'est à dire de jeu de les p55 elles
étaient 56 m'enfin camus mauriac ont été
donc à l'express en même temps et c'est
que jean max et moi je serai bien
pouvaient pas être des nôtres ce soir
puisque c'est tout vert à versailles
aujourd'hui le congrès radical mais je
suis allé le voir avec une équipe pour
le filmer et j'ai demandé à jean jacques
servan shreiber bien comment se fait-il
qu'il avait demandé à mauriac et un
camus ensemble leur collaboration et au
fond comment il est un journal sans les
trouver
pourquoi d'abord un évident à sa cause
de leur talent et puis parce que les
circonstances politiques exigeait que
les plus grands talents possible se met
au service du débat public
et quand je me souviens des deux qui ont
travaillé ensemble à l'express qui
écrivait en sorte qu'ils soient y est
fort peu et qui quand ils se rencontrent
dans le couloir se parlait à peine a
failli travailler ensemble donc j'avais
à faire aux deux ce qui me frappe c'est
ceci en apparence tout les différencie
leur origine sociale différence de
génération différence d'intérêts
l'europe est très différent donc entre
mauriac et camus on ne voit pas le lien
est en vérité ce qui m'a frappé en les
faisant travailler
c'est ce qui les rapproche et je dirais
deux choses essentiellement d'abord un
extrême sérieux dans le travail de
journaliste il prenait l'un et l'autre
bien que consacrer naturellement danse
écrivain le travail du journaliste très
au sérieux quand il fallait par exemple
couper un paragraphe parce que c'était
trop long et bien il le faisait il
venait au même il devenait jusqu'au
marbre pour couper eux mêmes et ils
prenaient le métier de journaliste
extrêmement au sérieux donnant un
exemple important éloquent à tous ceux
qui allaient les suire donc d'abord ce
sérieux et ensuite le courage je répète
leurs convictions leurs origines étaient
très différentes mais ils ont montré le
même genre de courage politique
mauriac d'abord mauriac vous en souvenez
avait une tribune en or il avait la une
du figaro de l'époque très grande
audience et le 10 en or du point de vue
de l'audience est pas du point de vue du
salaire et quitter le figaro est un très
grand journal pour venir à l'express qui
était un petit journal était un acte de
courage et pourquoi l'at-il fait parce
que le figaro ne le laissait pas écrire
exactement ce qu'ils entendent écrire
sur les problèmes de la crise coloniale
française en particulier à propos du
maroc et de la tunisie et plus tard de
l'algérie et donc il voulait une entière
liberté d'expression quel que soit
l'audience plus réduite que nous
pouvions lui offrir c'est donc un acte
de courage et camus de même camus était
quand je suis allé le trouver pour qui
le combattent avec nous plonger dans son
oeuvre
c'est avant qu'il ait le nobel et il se
consacrer à son avis l'avait décidé le
long mexique et de ne pas se mêler aux
joutes de la politique et de rester à
son travail décrivent et pierre
mendès-france et moi on lui parle
ensemble nous l'avons convaincu que son
talent serait très utile dans les
batailles de l'époque qui était celle du
colonialisme et de la réforme la société
française qui n'a pas cessé et camus
donc été très dérangés par cette demande
mais il l'a acceptée parce qu'il a
considéré que c'était son devoir et il
l'a fait ils ont ensuite fait acte de
courage dit aussi sincèrement lorsqu'ils
ont l'un et l'autre quitter l express
pas contre l'express mais l'un et
l'autre pour des raisons politiques de
profondes motivations mauriac pour
à mauriac est resté très longtemps à
écrire dans l'express avec le le brio et
les échos répercussions de ces articles
et puis par amour du général de gaulle
alors que l'express est avec moi
combattait la politique à l'époque d'une
arme good mauriac a considéré qu'il ne
pouvait pas recevoir chez lui dans le
bordelais la visionnaire le goût en
étant comme il l'a dit et écrit lié
d'une manière quelconque un journal qui
combattait la politique de goury a donc
cessé sa collaboration et n'a plus écrit
comme journaliste c'était aussi un acte
de courage et camus
c'était dans des circonstances encore
plus dramatique après le la journée du 6
février ou le présent du conseil qui
s'appelait guy mollet avait en somme
capitulé en souvenez devant les colons
d'algérie cam est venu me trouver et je
me souviens alors de minute en minute de
cette conversation dramatique où il m'a
dit à partir de maintenant je sais que
l'algérie est donc perdue je ne sais pas
quand mais elle l'est et je ne peux plus
écrire car ce que j'écrirai ne servirait
plus à rien il a donc cessé dans les
conditions également d'intégrité et de
courir voilà ce qui les rapproche
infiniment est profondément et ce second
je me rappelle de plus le plus intime et
le plus profond et sur lequel j'ai pas
fini de méditer pourtant ça fait
longtemps
ce camus c'est son discours au moment du
prix nobel
nous étions en pleine guerre d'algérie
et chacun d'entre nous vous êtes sans
doute trop jeunes chacun d'entre nous
lutter avec patients contre pour ou
contre moi contre
les guerres coloniales et camus a dit à
la tribune du nobel
si j'ai à choisir entre ma mère et la
justice je choisirai toujours ma mère
est une phrase profonde avec laquelle je
pense ma mère me comprendra en scène
l'amour sacré que je lui porte avec
laquelle je suis en complet désaccord
si j'ai à choisir entre ma mère et la
justice ne choisirai toujours si j'en ai
la force
l'injustice est cette phrase de camus
m'a donc profondément choqué et je n'ai
pas cessé d'y réfléchir parce que je ne
la comprends